الهوه بين فرنسا وايطاليا تتعمق اكثر
فاكثر باريس تنتقد وروما تستنكر ملف
الهجره يوتر العلاقات بين البلدين
وزير الفرنسي جيرال دارمانعه
بالعجز عن حل مشاكل الهجره في بلادها
قال ان حكومه اليمين المتطرف التي اختارها
اصدقاء مارينلوبين عاجزه عن ايجاد حلول
لمشاكل الهجره بعد من انتخبت على هذا
الاساس تصريحات اثارت حفيظه الحكومه
الايطاليه على خلفيه ذلك وزير الخارجيه
الايطالي انطونيو تجاني الغاز زياره كانت
مقرره الى باريس لن اذهب الى باريس
للمشاركه في الاجتماع الذي كان مقررا
اهانات وزير الداخليه جيرال دارمانان بحق
الحكومه وايطاليا غير مقبوله وز الخارجيه
الفرنسيه حاولت ان تخفف من حده التوتر اذ
اكدت ان فرنسا تريد العمل مع ايطاليا
لمواجهه تحدي الزياده السريعه في تدفق
المهاجرين بغض النظر عن تصريحات وزير
الداخليه
التعاون بين البلدين يرتكز في هذا الشان
على المهاجرين من وسط البحر الابيض
المتوسط لكن هذا التعاون ورجوع العلاقات
الى حالها الطبيعي امران قد يحتاجان الى
بعض الوقت حتى تعود المياه الى مجاريها
بلال البجدين العربيه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات